the White House is reversing a ban on
lobbyists we talk about money in
politics here every week this is pretty
much the root of all problems nobody is
debating that and the White House is on
the wrong side of it uh let's look a
little info this is from political the
new rule effects of policy implemented
in jun 2010 as part of Barack Obama's
ethics package but keep some of the ban
in place lobbyists will be allowed to
serve only in commissions and boards in
a representative capacity so long as
they're acting on behalf of a
corporation trade association or
industry group and not as private
citizens or representatives of the
government that seems object that it's
it can please go I think the opposite of
what you're supposed to do it's like
well if you want to cover is as innocent
okay but if you're gonna be representing
some big behemoth moneymaker who's gonna
undermine democracy no oh no it's the
opposite if you're if you're speaking
for someone who wants to undermine the
demand cratic process with money come on
in if your regular citizen no pound
sands why that the problem with this and
and the defense of the Obama
administration ears that they're
reacting to a court ruling that they
lost uh they were on the right side of
this it was not the strongest lobbyists
ban in the first place but now even the
moderate strength of it was undermined
it was under minded by the appellate
court so this goes to the point that the
wolf pack is involved and yet is that
unless you change the constitution is
really hard to do anything right and you
read the quotes in this story and it's
all about like the most powerful people
in the world saying finally we get a
seat at the table killer haha yeah they
are literally saying you only get a seat
at the table if you have money if you
are a regular citizen I just don't so
what's the administration why do this
wait they love it they work it over then
why push this even further I mean
they're just responding to the they're
largely responding to the defeat of a
court case here's where I don't look I
don't think they're like I can't believe
like this court case is devastating they
lost the court case let the guy yeah
yeah as the opposite of what George Bush
would have done he woulda just said well
we really don't agree that court's
decision we're gonna keep doing it this
way that's exactly what Barack Obama
should have said and who's good who's
what's he gonna do what you gonna dig
lose the
in the public opinion is not you say hey
you know I'm some fighting against
lobbyists here and that's a winner for
him but again it's he's that's not who
he is he's one of them people say why is
he dude he's got damn one of them so is
that the thing then that we've gotten so
we never talk we talk about it here but
the media literally never talks about
campaign finance anyway so is that why
for him it's not a winning it's not a
winning issue not that he needs to win
again but it's not even an issue for him
to go out on cuz nobody gives applause
but like for instance abortion the
publicans know it's never gonna be
overturned but they [ __ ] bring it up
every five seconds right cuz it's a big
winner for them politically this
actually could have traction in
legislators and get overturned as an
amendment or up yet and it's a political
winner and he still doesn't bring it up
there's a llama one it both ways with
everything I remember during the
campaign he kept saying how they're not
gonna use super PACs they're not going
to super PACs and then and then Romney
started using super PACs so then Obama
was like well we have no choice because
we have to do it so he kind of does want
it both ways cuz he knew that that was
ultimately gonna happen right the
Republicans were gonna do it then
everyone would be like well you gotta do
it too because this sucks so he you
gotta want both yeah i mean i would have
done same thing in that case I I
wouldn't family I would stand for the
game but it's the game it's important
that somebody says that the beat you
know it's important at least that we
talked about this is the first time we
really could in this last election talk
about super PACs so at least if somebody
says each time this is terrible maybe at
some point they'll go away it doesn't
seem like we're headed in that direction
right now